This is a very interesting new poll.
I think about 10 people in the last 12 or
so hours sent this to me and they want me
to talk about it.
So let's do it.
There's a question about the 2020 Democratic
primary that many people find important and
some don't.
And the question is, who of the Democratic
candidates would attract the most Trump voters?
People who voted Trump in 2016 who of the
Democratic candidates would have the highest
appeal to that group of people?
And I've said before, I don't think that the
way to win 2020 is by convincing Trump voters
to vote for a democrat.
Okay, we're much better off winning on turnout
since half the country doesn't vote.
Let's just make sure that people who are already
on our side understand the importance of voting
and choose to vote.
It is much easier to register 10 people to
vote than to convince a Trump is to vote for
a Democrat in 2020 but that being said, if
there is a candidate that is going to pull
way more Trumpists over to our side, it would
be important to know that.
And I would want to know that.
And then I can think about, well, is that
something that I want to consider when I'm
deciding who to support in the Democratic
primary?
So yesterday people started sending me a page
from a recent economist you gov poll, which
seems to say Bernie Sanders followed by Andrew
Yang would pull the most 2016 Trump voters
to our side.
So let's look at the poll numbers first.
And remember, I am just the Messenger here.
I am not arguing that this is the case.
I am merely showing you data from a poll,
which says this is the case.
So looking at this, you'll notice that from
the people pulled who voted Trump in 2016
this is the furthest right column on your
screen.
14% say they'd vote Bernie and 10% say they'd
vote for Andrew Yang.
And then in third place, 9% say they'd vote
for Pete Buddha judge.
So this is very interesting, the idea being
that Bernie Sanders is the candidate who would
most bring Trump voters to the democratic
side and that Andrew Yang is the second highest,
uh, candidate in terms of who would bring
Trump voters over to the democratic side.
Now this is very interesting, but if we want
to really evaluate this, we have to look at
the details because there are math questions
about this and there are also political questions
about those.
Let's start with the math.
You will notice at the bottom right of the
image that it says unweighted and 41 this
means that the sample size of Trump voters,
for this question, unweighted was 41 people
out of the 41 Trump voters included in this
sample, 14% said they'd vote Bernie and 10%
for Yang.
That's six people saying that they voted for
Trump in 2016 but would vote Bernie in in
2020 and four for Yang.
These are not exactly the large numbers around
which I would necessarily be taking away too
much, but that doesn't mean that the data
is not still interesting.
Now, more importantly, there's a political
question here.
Just because Trump is prefer Bernie and Yang
over whoever else, that doesn't mean they
would actually vote for them over Trump.
The question was, if the Democratic presidential
primary in your state were held today, who
would you vote for?
Okay.
Just because a Trumpist voting in the dem
primary would choose Bernie or Yang doesn't
mean they would choose Bernie or Yang over
Trump in the general election.
That's a really important thing to understand.
The other element of this is that you might
say, wait a second, why would Trumpists be
voting?
Why would Trump is who voted for Trump in
2016 even be voting in the 2020 Democratic
primary?
That's another relevant question because based
on how it is in the poll, the 41 people answering
that question are 2016 Trump voters who say
they will be voting in the 2020 Democratic
primary when the sample is 41 and we don't
know if there are people who are Republicans
in a state with an open primary who are going
to vote in the Democratic primary.
We don't know if some of them are lying about
having voted for Donald Trump.
planning to vote in the 2020 primary.
The point is when you've got just 41 people,
if just three people here lied, uh, then the
numbers all of a sudden become much less significant.
Now, all of that being said, to go back to
the initial question, with all of the things
that we can consider and thinking about which
2020 a democratic candidate we should be supporting,
I actually do not believe that picking a candidate,
because a slightly higher portion of Trumpists
would consider voting for them as a good strategy
because we are going to have to win despite
the Trumpists, not by convincing them and
big picture, particularly since a preference
for one Democrat over another does not tell
us that they would even vote for that person
over Trump in the general election.
I don't know that the right approach is to
be looking at polls and saying, well, 14%
would vote Bernie, 10% would vote Yang.
I'm going to make a decision on that basis.
I think we should be supporting the progressive
candidate.
I'm a progressive, so I want to look for a
progressive candidate whose policy ideas most
match ours period.
And then once we have a democratic nominee
selected, we should be working on get out
the vote.
Half the country doesn't vote.
Let's find people who are already sympathetic
to our political beliefs, but who may not
be planning to vote and get them to register
and vote.
Convincing Trumpists either by calculating
the Democratic nominee that would most appeal
to them or just like debating Trumpist and
trying to beat them over the head with logic
into voting for a democrat.
That is not the strategy that will remove
Trump in 2020.
If you disagree with me, I'm open to having
my mind changed.
Uh, follow me on Instagram at Davidson Dot
pacman and tell me exactly where and why you
disagree with me.
You can also follow the David Pakman show
on Instagram